detectives departing after more than 30
hours time spent scouring the home of
ex-smp Chief Peter Morrow the husband of
Nicola sturgeon
evidence gathering in a place police are
focused on as part of an investigation
on SMP funding and finances a probe that
led to the arrest and later release of
Morrow
well in Scott's law you can be arrested
and not charged but only held for a
maximum of 12 hours the purpose of that
12 hours is really to gather information
about potential crimes the pending
investigation means they are going to
look through all that material entering
the home of the new leader of Scotland
the official residence of Hamza Yusuf
someone now attempting to reset after
the departure of the country's political
power couple you touched on governance
and transparency within the party that
you're now leading is that an admission
that things were not quite right over
the course of the last couple of years
under Peter model's War that's an
admission that our governance our
transparency should have been better it
was Nicholas sturgeon too dominant in
your view I think in her own View and
her own words she was a dominant
political force there's now an
opportunity with her no longer the
leader of the party with Peter no longer
the chief executive to have a different
way of doing things this has been a
long-running probe stretching back to
March 2021 when a complaint was launched
with police about six hundred thousand
pounds raised to support a second
Independence referendum that made the
SNP National Treasurer resigned citing
Financial transparency concerns by July
detectives launch Operation Branch form
amid seven complaints fast forward to
December 2022 accounts commission
reports say Peter Morrow provided a
personal loan of more than a hundred
thousand pounds to the SMP around 18
months before by March after decades at
the top he quit after a row over
dwindling membership numbers
this Saga will no doubt be weighing
heavy on Nicholas sturgeon who has not
been seen in public she was due to
appear here at this venue in Edinburgh
to discuss climate change but pooled out
a sign that the crisis in her personal
life was at risk of overshadowing
proceedings
as the police presence moves away the
job of sifting and scrutinizing any
evidence begins Connor Gillis Sky News